well folks we are not going to be
getting those secret service text
messages many of you i know have been
following this story this week anxiously
awaiting yesterday tuesday when
supposedly
the text messages deleted by the secret
service
after they were told don't delete these
text messages preserve records they are
not going to be able to able to turn
them over to the january 6th committee
investigating the trump riots this is a
really really big deal this really
actually should be a major scandal and i
don't know if it's going to become one
as it seems even the secret service
under trump which we suspected we talked
about it at the time even the secret
service under trump supposedly
in theory apolitical uh has fallen fell
under the thumb of wacky trumpism so
let's reset the story
the january 6th committee
subpoenaed some u.s secret service
records
because um a government watchdog found
believed that the agency had erased
important text messages from january 5th
and january 6th 2021.
the secret service uh was told even if
these were deleted you have to recover
them and there were conflicting and
changing explanations as to why the
secret service didn't have them first it
was something related to
changes to the
pieces of equipment elements of
technology that they were using they did
a phone migration well it turns out that
that phone migration started after the
request for these text messages so it's
all increasingly
more and more fishy and now we learn
you're not going to get the text
messages
uh washington post report secret service
cannot
okay cannot recover texts no new details
for the january 6th committee the u.s
secret service has determined it has no
new text messages to provide congress
relevant to its january 6th
investigation and that any other texts
its agents exchanged around the time of
the trump riots were purged purged also
the national archives sought more
information on the potential
unauthorized deletion
of agency text messages the u.s
government's chief record keeper asked
secret service to report back within 30
days about the deletion of records
including describing what was purged and
the circumstances of how the
documentation was lost it's just gone
guys and yes it's as suspicious as such
as a a situation as it sounds it is
amazing what you are unable to do
when you're determined not to do
something and i'm reminded of donald
trump and his tax records donald trump
was obviously from day one determined
never to publish his private tax records
it was abundantly clear and so first it
was well i'm under ardet as he liked to
say from the irs and once the audits are
complete then but wait sir which years
are under audit it could give us
something it can't be that every year of
recent taxes is well i'm under audit i'm
under audit and my lawyers say don't do
it oh okay so then after well no and
well now it's re-election it's four
years later you're not still being
audited for those same years are you
well i don't know the american people
don't care about that he was determined
not to publish his tax returns
and he didn't publish them the secret
service here was clearly determined not
to recover
or provide or publicize or deliver these
text messages
and that's exactly what they're doing so
now we have at least
a reasonable suspicion that secret
service was involved complicit
indifferent to what was going on on
january 6th now let's add to that
add to our understanding
this
seemingly strange data point mike pence
didn't want to get in the car with
secret service on that day
that's weird but we didn't really know
what to make of it at least not
initially it kind of doesn't make sense
why wouldn't the if secret service comes
to the vice president and says uh mr
vice president sir
we've got to get you out of here it's
not safe
and pence goes i'm not going i'm not
getting in a car with you guys
that is strange but it was sort of out
of context initially do we now have a
little bit more of the picture where
secret service here
seemingly for what appear to be
political reasons i mean there's been no
other explanation given the explanations
about technological reasons shifted oh
it was a data migration it was new
devices it was these different things
that none of it makes sense
but what now does make some sense
is the idea that pence knew
what we're increasingly aware of which
is that even the secret service
was
not infiltrated but taken over
by trump loyalists if you think back to
when trump was in the hospital with
covid
and on day two
trump insisted on going out for this joy
ride with his mask on to wave to people
around walter reed hospital and we all
said that's hugely irresponsible he's
stuffing a bunch of seeds he's he's very
sick and he's stuffing secret service
agents into the vehicle and we heard
anecdotally oh some of the secret
service agents didn't like it they were
exposed high rate of covert among them
maybe most of them are actually okay
with it i mean at the end of the day
if it was trump loyalists hand-picked
even within secret service to be around
maybe they thought it was cool that he
was going around and saying hi to the
people so
that's increasingly the picture we have
of secret service under trump now
separately
what's going on with merrick garland
merrick garland is attorney general
and so far
he's shown no willingness willingness to
really go after high-level people
potentially involved with criminality
related to january 6 related to the
post-election period what's going on at
doj we don't know
this
is investigation worthy the secret
service should be investigated over
these deleted texts by the highest level
and that would be as a federal agency
that would be by the department of
justice
is that going to happen
is there any evidence merit garland is
willing to do that it's an
extraordinarily suspicious timeline
congress tells the secret service
preserve the documents from january 5
and 6
on january 16th it had only been 10 days
january 16 2021 congress says keep the
documents and then again they say that
on january 25th and then two days later
this is now two weeks after being told
keep the records
the secret service starts a phone
migration
and all of a sudden it's all gone and we
can't get any of it this is major news
this should be a major scandal we will
see where it goes
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chili sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well chili sleeps product the
uhler the cube and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get thirty percent off of
the uler and cube sleep systems and 10
off the new dock pro this offer is only
for my audience the link is down below